the homecoming of WNBA Superstar
Brittany Greiner have you heard she's
landed in San Antonio this morning very
early this morning after a prisoner
exchange for a Russian arms dealer
Greiner was detained in February at a
Moscow airport for having cannabis oil
cartridges in her luggage there was
residue in those cartridges that's been
described as less than the size of a
raisin the two-time Olympic gold
medalist was playing basketball in
Russia during the WNBA offseason other
players went online to share their joy
that Greiner BG is what they call her is
free her teammate Brianna Turner told us
she's been pushing to keep greiner's
name in the headlines and had just
tweeted about her
I think about PG daily and like I
oftentimes tweet about her and I've been
asking about her last night probably the
deal had like already went through and I
woke up this morning and it's like my
dreams came true
a lot of people's dreams came true
yesterday Brianna joining us now is the
WNBA commissioner that's Kathy Engelbert
Kathy it's good to see you thank you for
joining us today
Gail great to be here great day
yesterday with the news about this
return so thanks so much I know
I'm with Brianna shirelle told us that
she just can't stop smiling that her
face hurts so much from smiling I feel
exactly the same and I don't even know
Brittany Greiner so I can't imagine what
it's like for you guys in the WNBA uh
family so take us to the moment where
you heard where were you what did you do
what did you think
well for a couple days we knew that the
negotiations were intensifying and quite
frankly the state department and the
administration have been working on this
for months and months and
um so it's as you know Gail very
geopolitically complex and um so in the
last couple days we knew it was
intensifying but you don't know whether
this is going to happen until it
actually gets executed and we knew there
was no path legally or diplomatically
and we knew this prisoner exchange was
the only option for many many months so
the joy and gratitude that you heard
from WNBA players who have advocated in
the whole basketball ecosystem has
advocated for Brittany including NBA
players since this began and just the
joy and gratitude yesterday and you know
presidents get elected to make hard
decisions and and the administration
came through in the state department and
this group and the state department
called the special presidential Envoy
for hostage Affairs they're the rock
stars in this as well they work
tirelessly and they would tell me we're
all Britney all the time full court
press every basketball analogy but they
have a birthday card on getting our home
you know what Kathy I think there's a
lot of rock stars in this scenario I
can't wait till we hear the full details
of how it all came together it's been
reported that uh Brit that you wrote
letters to Brittany Greiner while she
was in prison what did she tell you what
did you all communicate with each other
during that time
right so right because we couldn't do
phone calls her family couldn't do phone
calls as a mom I can't imagine the
anguisher mom and dad and the pain they
went through and now being able to
reunite with her and shirelle as well
but she wrote a hand wrote me a letter
because when she was in the Detention
Center uh near Moscow she was able to
write handwritten letters give them to
her lawyers who got them to us so we
wrote her about every six weeks because
we were in season the players were
missing her so much the players were
writing her inspiring letter back short
letter but inspiring around her
gratitude for everything she knew we
were doing and I was doing and just
really just she really wanted to get
home so obviously you know yesterday was
a great day to hear this news
commissioner I've been talking with
other professional athletes in the topic
of conversation is her playing again
which is going to take
um you know something physical out of
her to get back into shape but I said
well before we start talking about her
playing
um what is she going to do when it comes
to Preparing her mentally because she
went through a lot over the last year
what is the NBA the WNBA excuse me going
to do to help her find some normalcy
absolutely so first she needs time and
space spend time with family being
evaluated obviously for her physical and
mental well-being and that's happening
over the next day or so and then
obviously we have mental health
resources available from a league
perspective from her team perspective
she had played for Phoenix Mercury and
so all of that is available to her but
we want to give her time and space we
all want to go fly to her we all want to
go talk with her the players are very
anxious to reconnect especially the
players on our team and USA basketball
as well so we'll give her time and space
and we'll be there for her whatever she
needs from a mental perspective but
you're right mental emotional and
physical are things that you know that
recovery is going to take a while I am
sure
yeah we can all agree with that Kathy uh
in addition to time and space uh you
know WNBA players they need money and
part of the reason why uh Brittany
grinder was playing in Russia in the off
season is because she's trying to
supplement her salary here in America
and it raises the larger question of how
you and the league can make sure that
the women playing for you are making the
living they need so they don't need to
be in what turned out to be a very
dangerous situation
yeah so we are in a full out when I came
in as commissioner full out
transformation of the league economics
trying to build an economic model but
when less than one percent of all
corporate sponsorship dollars go towards
women's sports and less than five
percent of all media coverage covers
women's sportship 40 percent of the
athletes in America are women so we're
trying to chip away at an economic model
so in the last collective bargaining we
tripled the top player pay in which
Britney is one of the greatest players
ever to play the game so she was making
the super max as well as you can make
now up to seven hundred thousand dollars
for your four and a half month season
here but we we are we're literally
transforming and players are also
choosing to stay home we have 10 players
under player marketing agreements where
we'll pay those players million and a
half dollars over the course of the off
season we also have players who are
doing broadcast like a Candace Parker
and a Chana gumacay and we also have
Skyler Diggins out in Phoenix and Kia
nurse up in Toronto doing broadcast in
our off season when it's the season for
the NBA as well as
um college basketball a lot of our our
players are now assistant coaches and
things so we're finding opportunities
internships other things to make sure
that the players can make some money in
the off season in addition to driving
higher pay during our season
yeah so more more work to be done there
Kathy but we can all focus on the good
news today Brittany Greiner steps back
on American soil just a few hours ago uh
Kathy thank you very much for sharing
some time with us this morning
thank you so much
well thank you